nicole kidman you have been dragged
kicking and screaming into the 21st
century you've joined the Instagram not
kicking in scream oh you you've embraced
it I kind of went oh okay this is yeah
this is me having some fun and there I
am I'm in it now but now there is an IED
abble yes if you have heart sale if you
haven't fallen to there's a lot of cat
action I sell riveting no wait I'm about
to get you a lot of followers here cause
you posted this action sequence this is
in LA
I know it yeah yes yes are you talking
about this yes yeah so and there's the
screaming sounds I presume do your
children yes who sound do sound
terrified and then we can see why epic I
must just say before we watch this given
you work in film yeah camera work isn't
great you were very nervous at the time
you were very nervous so would excuse at
all this is at the Cole filming in her
garden in LA
[Music]
don't care this spider
help it's the size of your head what did
you mean because it's one thing to get
it in the jam jar what no it was very
hard getting it in the jar I put the jar
on it and then it knocked the jar over
is it tarantula
but I'm Australian we grew up with
spiders horse so but I did and I
released the spider I have to say I'm
one of those people that doesn't kill
anything in neighbours go I don't
anything sell anything us sing to the
screen was that real I'm like yeah it's
totally real I'm going to Australia next
year should I that was in LA sorry okay
fine you're all right you're fine I was
gonna say you grew up there yeah I'm not
frightened of snakes either I don't have
a no I'm kind of very I'm very into
reptiles and insects good to know
[Music]